I've sorta for today we talk about DNS
or the domain name system this is a
service that runs on all of our
computers but obviously is is run mostly
over the Internet by big servers the
idea is that we want to try and resolve
IP addresses to domain names
I go to youtube.com then at some point
I'm gonna have to work out what the IP
address of that service if I can ask it
using HTTP to give me some some amazing
computer file videos right so to do that
it needs to be some system in place
because me just guessing an IP could
take quite a long time so the domain
name system is the the the system we use
to to do this so I'm gonna type in Ivor
on a URL bar in my browser or on the
command line a and I a domain name and
then it's gonna have to be resolved to
an IP and then I can actually
communicate with that server to do
whatever it was I want to do so just to
clarify if I put it in computer file dot
website or something that something
somewhere needs to know where it's at
yeah there'll be usually one or two or
four tative name servers which are
serviced that can specifically say it's
this IP right and I have no idea where
they are that's not the point by the
point if we can find out where they are
this is the mechanism that DNS uses we
don't know where anything is so we ask a
few things that we know where they are
and then they help us on and we kind of
keep asking we keep asking going to door
to door and then eventually find out
what the answer is or we don't and then
you get a couldn't find a dns couldn't
find a domain no website so let's
imagine that I've gone to my I've gone
to my browser or I've typed ping
google.com or something like that so my
computer will have a cache of lots of
domain names that I've visited recently
but they will ask maybe one or two hours
for ones on my computer so let's assume
that we've just turned a computer on
after a week or something like that and
and so it doesn't know where google.com
is it will have to make him a DNS query
to find out what it is now the first
point of contact will usually be a name
server belongs over to you know your
organization that you're in so let's say
the University nothing will have a name
server or two will be your ISP if you
live at home probably or you might have
configured something like Open DNS
yourself and you might have one yourself
but let's assume before for the sake of
argument that we're using our know ISPs
domain name server right so so this is
our computer here and we want to go to
some website so let's say Google calm
now
we don't know what the IP address of
google.com so we're gonna have to ask
some other computer that might know what
would normally happen here is we would
ask an a name server that we've either
configured ourselves or that is let's
say given to us by our ISP right so I'm
going to connect to my ISPs server here
is P and this is their name server and
I'm gonna say google.com question mark
all right I mean there'll be a few other
bits of information in that dot just
Google calm in it's a rhetorical
question
now this server will either know because
it has a little cache of of stuff that
it can look up right now if someone else
has been to google.com recently which is
obviously quite likely it would know
what that is and it will give that
information back but let's assume that
it doesn't and let's also assume that
this is set up to be what we would call
it recursive resolver so that means it
can not only answer queries about DNS
but it can also ask queries about the NS
it's got to ask another machine that it
thinks might know the answer now it
hasn't got the foggiest idea right
because there are a lot of different IP
addresses so what it's going to do is
it's going to pick pick from a list of
root name servers all right so it's
going to talk up here on the Internet to
a root name server so the name server
will go off to the root name server of
which there's about 20 that these are
hard-coded
it all computers have access to these I
think one of them's run by Verisign for
example one run by NASA no I I don't
know what but it is so this root name
server will say I don't know I don't
know what Google coms don't I pay
address is this this day right because
they maybe they turn a computer off and
on again and it's chained so what I do
know is that this IP address of this
global top-level domain name server
could help you right and there might be
a few of these as well so it's gonna
send us a.com name server right or
multiple ones and wrong pick one now
viscom name server we're getting a
little bit closer so it's kind of
working away backwards through the URL
in some sense or through the domain name
so we will put in a request to viscom
name server it will say I don't actually
know
but I do know that the next place you
should ask or be kind of the name server
that's responsible for this zone is
let's say n s1 google.com or something
like that now we're getting a lot closer
right this is a good name server let's
let's say hypothetically it's run by
Google they're going to know what their
own ideas are right if they don't then
Google isn't gonna work but this is like
lesson 1 of web administration so we
actually put in a request to ns1 Google
to come this is another referral sort of
spelt right with a bit of mess with my
pen and they're going to send back when
we actually query and it's one of Google
calm what is Google calm it will finally
actually tell us it is you know 10 or
1.2 right now it definitely isn't that
but you know it could you know that's
the idea so we finally have an IP
address now what we can actually do now
is send an HTTP GET request or paying or
whatever it is we want to do to that IP
and then we can get a response so that's
how it works
now the DNS service is a little bit more
clever than than this sort of overview
right because of its caching and stuff
like this so I have a cache here and
this recursive resolver water have a
cache and any other was always involved
will also have a cache they suppose that
this is peas name server is serving
10,000 customers I all of whom were
going to Google this is a bit of a waste
of time I'm especially given that Google
probably not changing their IP every
hour and so the first person in the
morning that gets up and goes to Google
comm is going to have to wait factions
of a second longer because it's going to
be doing this but then Google Chrome
will be put into this cache with a time
to like time to live and then for that
amount of time basically just serve that
straight back all right so what is
Google to comp it's this right it's ten
dot Nord or 1.2 whatever and that means
that this this name server which will be
quite powerful conserve all the ISPs
customers really really quickly which is
kind of neat this is basically a
distributed database this name server is
going to be putting in lots and lots of
requests right to hundreds of servers
probably per second the critic all view
people on the internet asking I want to
go to random website calm random website
calm
website random and so on and it's going
to be doing all this how does it know
what to do with any of this all this
gibberish few informations coming back
well what it does is it has a query ID
which it sends out whenever it sends out
a request and the name server responds
will respond with the same query ID so
it's labeled it's labeled right so and
that allows it to sort through the mess
a little bit more and it leads to a
slightly interesting quirk which is that
if I send a response to a name server
but it didn't want but I get the query
ID right it will accept it which is for
a different video
that's DNS cache poisoning for the most
part that doesn't happen right for the
most part the query IDs match anything
works out quite well and it's really
really quick
so what is she it's a corn snake Bambino
corn snake but she's in the middle of
shedding and she's she's grumpy and
hiding under a rock and probably asleep
so you know that's his best the best of
you you're gonna get and it might all
might see her another time yeah that's
what